because you're my wife and you love the
theater and it's your birthday
great unfortunately the um the orchestra
is already filled up but they do have
seats that are still left in the dress
Circle so if you want to um me to get
them theater tickets right now I'm gonna
do it right now what's up dog I'm about
five minutes away yeah okay yeah cool no
they're all good singers They're all
good singers
nah man I'm about I'm telling you man
I'm about to cross the street I get that
one dude in it that you love man he
gonna be in it yeah come on now you know
I'm almost there all right right now I'm
gonna pick your ass up at 6 30 then cool
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah the
parking is uh the park is free
somebody got that oh my God Christian I
almost totally just got mugged right now
all right where you hit it youngster
yeah I'm uh headed to the Kobo building
on Jefferson all right yeah Cobo Hall
Jefferson Avenue
so uh what you in Detroit for I gotta do
a presentation all right okay yeah
presentation okay
what do you present
uh actually it's about how market
research can be interpreted with out of
the box Solutions oh all right so you
won't get this all outside the box all
right
most people think that all customers are
a single demographic oh okay you I get
all them demographics up in here all
right all right yeah
online Trends are less linear oh okay on
on trans
[Music]
also thinking about doing the
presentation naked there's no no clothes
on oh yeah yeah naked presentation no
clothes on that's good
afterward I might just piss on the floor
in front of everyone oh yeah okay all
right piss him right there up in front
of everybody all right sounds good then
I might just shoot everybody in the
place you know with the gun I'm hiding
in my ass yeah yeah gone way up in that
ass that's the way to do it I'll cut my
victims faces off wear them as masks
yeah masks go on the face yeah okay
YouTube
all right here we are
oh by the way when you kill those people
with your ass gun make sure to use a
serrated blade to cut the faces off
I'll feed the same
just got to check yeah
damn
look how much I lost in taxes damn
government look at that might as well
join the teapot excuse me what did you
just say might as well join the Tea
Party
come with me what's going on you are the
chosen one the hell are you talking
about man we've been waiting for you
waiting for me what the hell is this I
found them
them what you were telling your friend I
hate taxes what do you find appealing
about the politics of the Tea Party I'm
not a politician a real man of the
people how do you feel about the Second
Amendment man I don't want this taken
away from you just like the rest of us
one of many issues you're passionate
about oh
trial
now come meet your public what are you
talking about I ain't got no public what
is this ladies and gentlemen the new
leader of the Minnesota tea party and
the next president of the United States
what's your name Terrell Jackson perfect
Terrell Jackson
look look I I don't want any part of
this all right you hate the government
that's great you know what show us your
gun again look y'all are just
creepy but you can have this back
and another black guy
[Music]
oh
oh hey good to see you thanks for having
us this is my girlfriend we're so happy
you could join us and this is my wife
so this is the infamous and
has told me so much about you both all
good things I hope you can never trust
and please please don't call me makes me
think my mother's around someplace oh
hey you know where is little oh she's at
house for a slumber party
[Music]
uh there was this is the couple from New
York that we wanted you guys to meet uh
this is and her husband
uh they're gonna be in New York for a
few weeks so we were hoping you could
give them some tips I'm sure that'd be
great so how do you know and
oh well and I went to
School of dramatic arts back when I was
working in Midtown oh no where did you
work I was at uh
and
[Music]
it's so good to see you hey everybody
this is
I want you to meet one of my dearest
oldest friends this is his girlfriend
of course you know this is and this is
her husband
hi what a beautiful name you know I
knewa
[Music]
in grad school oh well thank you but
it's actually pronounced
[Music]
wow I swear that sounds like what you
were saying
anyways it's lovely to meet you all yes
Robert
I'm so sorry Heinrich
show myself to the restroom
for sake
okay I'm sorry I'm talking at the same
time as you okay you go ahead and talk
I'm sorry go ahead no it's all right
are you talking right now are you trying
to
go ahead this is
go ahead okay go ahead
no
weak gosh are you talking right now
damn it okay
you golfers no
wait what's that what wait
what
ridiculous gotta have this conversation
okay okay okay
did you catch up
we wouldn't be talking at the same time
God damn it
okay okay
let me just look at the same time
or this conversation it's gonna just go
on
no
one thing we can do no listen to me I
don't know we gotta end it we I gotta
end it I can't I can't do it anymore
okay fine I can't do it then we're gonna
end it okay we're gonna end I got it I
can't do it Keegan
Keegan I'm gonna end it you're Frozen I
can't tell we're gonna end it okay
I just don't want you to be offended
ending it and oh
oh he really meant ended
hey man yeah
you got it
yeah I got it
what you doing okay
what
what the hell are you doing uh I'm just
trying to give you the money don't
whisper don't whisper to speak like a
normal individual all right act natural
and just give me the money okay okay
okay okay okay I will do that thank you
hey man what's up what you doing what's
with the Robin Williams routine man
what's going on here why you playing in
the cheap seats I'm just trying to act
I'm just trying to I'm trying to act
natural well why are you jumping in
between different characters to do so
I'm not I'm not doing that what am I
trying to if anything I'm changing my
volume you acting like someone who's
trying to hide it you know who tries to
hide it dudes who's buying drugs all
right okay you looking like the most
drugs
okay dude stop saying the word drugs
damn
don't judge me
that just take out your money
and fan it
fan it fan it you know how to fan money
thank you no fan it out
good
now give it to me
good that's all there is to it here come
the drug machine
all right just high five and say drugs
drugs
unreal look at these clowns those two
not them them
Sully make it to Westeros they're gonna
annihilate wait wait dude it's gonna be
crazy slow down second of all I'm not up
to that yet oh I'm sorry oh yeah I
didn't know that I think
I'm like dude you know what I'm saying
like a Jordan right now but right now
you must listen to how this white dude
is talking to black people get out of my
face we have Tommy Bahama ass I'm trying
to make some beef yo I'm a DJ
hey how's it going key and peel right
good so start you guys are here thanks
for coming out you guys rock awesome
yo cup it let me get some Red Vines
wanna get out of here yep
[Music]
oh